crois qu'on t'a pas ah les garçons mais
où tirez-vous passer j’étais fou
d'inquiétude pardon on est désolé
des produits vegasus
vous deviez faire quelques courses et
rentrer juste après mettez-vous
on est vraiment désolé d'être il voulait
aller voir un film j'ai essayé de les
raisonner Léo vous êtes allé voir un
film avec les humains Bart il rat qui
quittent le navire n'utilise pas cette
expression
[Musique]
ce soir maître splinter nous a confié
une mission très importante la cible de
l'autre côté de la rue on doit agir avec
discrétion et ruses pour infiltrer le
monde des humains et récupérer
un paquet de nouilles un paquet
votre motivation
sans crème et fruits des légumes et un
paquet de ritos
charges du papier toilette RAF tu
remplis le garde-manger et Mickey tu
fais le plein de John food souvenez-vous
aucun humain ne doit nous voir vous vous
rappelez pourquoi les humains sont la
vermine démoniaque de la terre il faut
les éviter il faut pas les saluer ils
adorent massacrer tout ce qui leur
ressemble pas interagir avec eux ben
écoutez la vie et je sais que c'est
carrément un préjugé mais c'est ce que
papa nous a appris moi je trouve les
humains plutôt sympa franchement Beyoncé
et les jeux vidéos c'est encore mieux
les pizzaiolo les gamers pizzaiolo les
gamers pizzaiolo qui font du breakdance
écoutez on pense tout ce que les humain
S sont cool mais on a une mission au
boulot au boulot